for my next guest it was like any other
day work the gym returning home to his
family his wife and his five-month-old
at home waiting for him but as he was
unlocking the door two armed thugs
shoved a gun in his face tried to push
their way through the door well it was
then that he did what any responsible
concealed handgun permit holder would do
he decided to defend himself and his
family and a gunfight ensued now
everyone's safe but those arm robbers
are still on the loose but even worse
perhaps California has revoked that
man's permit to carry again the Golden
State values strike again joining me now
is Vince Richie the man who defended his
family and Co anoir who's a second
amendment Advocate and attorney Vince
let me start with you uh tell us very
briefly very briefly what happened well
thank you very much for having me here I
was coming home after a day of work in
the gym and exactly like you said and
the thing I never thought was going to
happen happened I I turned around to the
surprise of two armed gunmen trying to
get into my home and the first thing I
thought was my family and there's no way
I'm letting this
happen and did you do you carry
regularly I know you're a concealed
carry uh permit but do you carry
regularly at at the time I wasn't really
carrying because I never thought that I
was going to have to use it I never
really thought I never wanted to know
that I thought that this was really
going to happen but after seeing this
uptick and crime and homelessness and
just became commonplace that robberies
were going to happen I said this is a
responsibility I need to take but it's
not even a CCW matter because I was on
my own property I was walking in to the
driveway and the entryway of my house so
this Petty attempt for them to strip me
of my ability to carry outside of my
house for something to happen on my
property it it's just
unexplainable ah I see what you're
saying well DC has uh really strict
concealed carry rules R you have to
register one gun at a time so is the gun
you use registered as a concealed carry
yes the gun a Glock 26 is registered as
my one concealed carry which I at the
time like I said I never really thought
I was going to have to use it and I went
about it the right way I acquired it the
right way they granted me the right to
carry now they're stripping me with the
men at lodge that were looking for me
and not giving the ability to defend
myself and I hope what's the
reason what's the reason
I mean I think it's pretty blatant what
the reason is California has has had a
notorious reputation for being anti-gun
and anti anybody being able to carry a
firearm unless you're part of the
government somehow so this aspect of
them stripping him stripping him of his
ability to carry a firearm especially
when we're talking about a situation
that happened on his property it just
reeks of their hatred for Citizens law-
abiding citizens for that matter being
able to carry firearms to protect
themselves well I have to say Vince you
know Nome did propose that 28th
Amendment to the US Constitution which
would you know you know preserve the
language of the Second Amendment but
then add a whole bunch of new
requirements and limitations to uh gun
ownership in the United States that you
know they claim is you know very very
popular and people would want but he's
notoriously anti-gun rights I don't care
what he tries to say Nome is one of the
worst in California I think is the
second most poorly rated State as far as
gun rights in the United States I think
we'll even put up a a a graphic that
shows us the worst states for uh gun
rights in the United States but Vince is
there any doubt on your mind that
California at this point especially
where you live it's a pro-criminal
jurisdiction it's not prun rights people
it's Pro criminal absolutely the
sheriff's attempt now at coming after me
is petty I think Luna should step up and
actually represent the citizens the good
giving back citizens that give back
through the community and not partake in
the criminal activity that's happening
because they're not getting arrested
they're not going after them they're
trying to restrict
me yeah the best states we just put up
Arizona Utah Alaska and so forth
Washington DC California Maryland New
Jersey among the absolute worst and and
by the way I want to I want to bring
this up you know col in in Florida
violent crime fell by 32% in
2022 uh and then compared to California
while California violent crimes spiked
133% last year compared to 2019 so what
would you say to Nome uh colan about
this approach to people like Vince who
are trying to defend his family on his
own property given what the people of LA
and LA County especially San Francisco
were
saying well first of all I think I think
first of all Newsome needs to stop
focusing on this issue from a position
of control because if you were really if
you really talking about keeping people
safe and saving people's lives what you
would do is you would Empower people to
be able to protect themselves since it's
clearly been demonstrated that the
police can't be there when Vince was at
home and the guys were jumping over his
wall was Joe Biden there to help him was
there a cop there to help him was Gavin
Newsome there to help stop those
criminals no they weren't it was just
Vince and those two guys and yet and
still they create law after law after
law which makes it even harder for
someone Vince to be able to protect
himself from two people with firearms
and then you mentioned the whole point
about the 28th Amendment the mere fact
that he's trying to push this
demonstrates how much he hates the
Second Amendment because if he
understood the constitution in the
Second Amendment it was written to tell
the government what they can't do
against our ability to own and carry
firearms but yet he's creating an entire
Amendment which limits that ability
that's insane to
me uh Vince you're going to get your
concealed carry permit back if uh we
have anything to say about it Vincent
col thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else